it doesn't get more succinct than a mere
hello
that was u.s president joe biden's
response when asked if he had a message
for north korean leader kim jong-un but
he offered a lengthier answer when asked
how the u.s and south korea would deal
with nuclear or missile threats
we are prepared for anything north korea
does we've had we fought through how we
respond to whatever they do and so i'm
not concerned if that's what you're
suggesting
just before he left for tokyo to
continue his tour of asia biden and
south korean president yun sukyo visited
an air force command center
the air and space operation center here
is a key place for the republic of korea
and the united states to jointly respond
to the increasingly sophisticated north
korean nuclear and missile threats and
it is a symbol of the republic of korea
and u.s alliance
the joint appearance the choice of
location to showcase the country's
strong security alliance
a day earlier the two leaders had agreed
to step up military exercises and
possibly deploy more strategic weapons
to the region to counter north korean
threats
there was also an offer to return to
negotiations although some analysts say
north korea is unlikely to respond just
yet i think they're waiting to gauge
uh what is going on with the new
president of south korea uh president
yun sukyo
and uh they already know a lot about
biden from his past dealings uh in the
u.s senate and as vice president
so i think they're just going to sort of
bide their time and see what cooperative
efforts may be in the future
north korea is dealing with a severe
outbreak of covet 19 and has not
responded to international offers of
assistance including from the u.s
but biden's visit was as much about
security as it was about the economy and
he used it to highlight multi-billion
dollar investments south korean
companies were making in the us
biden will be in japan till tuesday
where he's expected to continue with the
overarching theme of his trip to asia
that the us is committed to the region
and although he's not said this
explicitly analysts say the u.s wants
countries in the region to see it as a
counterweight to china's rising
influence florence louis al jazeera
seoul
and rob mcbride is in tokyo he looks
ahead to the agenda in japan
president joe biden comes to japan with
the view to strengthen ties with this
very important ally in northeast asia at
a time when the united states and japan
face a number of challenges on a number
of different fronts this is meant to
send a message to north korea at a time
of increased missile testing and
speculation about a possible nuclear
test it also is meant to send a very
clear signal to beijing about its
increasing assertiveness in the
asia-pacific region and its territorial
demands that is something which is felt
very keenly here in japan which is in
dispute with china over various
territorial claims in the east china sea
with events in ukraine i think it also
sends a very strong message to russia
the united states is leading the
international community in its
condemnation also in boycotts and
sanctions it is something which is
supported by japan and in fact the u.s
has praised japan for rallying other
countries in asia pacific to also
condemn russia for its actions all of
these things will be discussed in the
next couple
of days this central part of tokyo the
streets at the moment are quiet this
sunday but there is a very uh very
strong police presence and in the next
couple of days there will be all sorts
of motorcades back and forth to these
meetings where all of these issues will
be discussed culminating in a meeting on
tuesday of the so-called quad security
alliance of uh japan united states
australia and india again this loose
alliance which is
meant to try to constrain china's
diplomatic and military ambitions in
asia pacific